Jack-Jack crashing Edna's fashion show, the
return of Kari the babysitter, and the reveal
of Frozone's wife are just some of the amazing
scenes cut from Pixar's Incredibles 2.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be revealing and explaining
five Incredibles 2 deleted scenes that you
probably wish Pixar had included in the movie.
Plus keep watching to the end for an extra
Edna and Jack-Jack clip where I'll reveal
two new Jack-Jack powers we never saw in the
main movie.
If this is your first time here, I do regular
deep dives into your favourite Pixar, Disney
and superhero movies so tap the bell to keep
up to date with all my new videos.
"FROZONE: Honey?"
"What?"
"FROZONE: Where's my supersuit?"
"I had to..
I'm washing it!"
"FROZONE: Don't lie to me!
I keep that suit spotless!"
"FROZONE: And you better not be trying to
hide it on me!"
"It.. it was filthy!"
"FROZONE: It was next to godliness clean and
ready for action!"
"I'm not playing with you."
"It was filthy!"
"How dare you?!"
"How dare you.."
"Aha!"
"Lucius don't you think you can get away from
me!"
"Lucius!"
Now, I
really wish this scene had been in the movie.
It's a wonderful callback to that hilarious
scene in the first Incredibles where Frozone
goes searching for his supersuit after looking
out the window and seeing Syndrome's Omnidroid
wreaking havoc on the city.
"Where is my supersuit?"
"HONEY: I put it away."
This time around it's Honey who spots the
Underminer's enormous drilling machine causing
chaos and who then hilariously and frantically
tries to find somewhere to hide Frozone's
suit.
I think it would have been nice to see the
woman behind the voice especially as she was
such huge hit with fans in the first movie.
Incredibles 2 director Brad Bird has said
this original scene took too much momentum
away from the Underminer action sequence at
the beginning of the movie and he felt that,
in the end, Honey was funnier as a voice as
that way everyone who watches the film can
have their own idea of what she looks like.
Although I can see Bird's perspective up to
a point and I enjoyed Incredibles 2, I can't
help but think this extra scene with Honey
would have just been fantastic.
Fun fact: The design for Honey in this deleted
clip was actually reused later in the movie
for one of the other supers who assemble on
the Deavor's yacht.
Edna and Jack-Jack's scenes together are some
of the funniest in Incredibles 2 and there's
some amazing bonus material on the Blu-ray
which reveals some great extra scenes with
the two characters.
The first is a deleted scene where Edna is
hosting her own fashion show which Jack-Jack
accidentally and amusingly interrupts.
"E, I'm operating on no sleep."
"I'm telling you this baby is freaking me
out!"
"Yes."
"I don't know where he's gonna be, I don't
know what he's gonna be."
"Robert!"
"Anything can happen and I've got to respond."
"What, what?"
"The baby is gone."
"What is it Humphrey?"
"They're going crazy, they want you to take
a bow."
"And they want the glitter baby."
"No glitter baby!"
"First the team will bow, then the junior
designers, then I will come."
"No glitter baby."
This is a great scene that I'm sure many fans
would have loved to have seen in the final
film.
It shows how Edna's real passion is designing
outfits for Supers, but because they're illegal
she has to work with supermodels who we already
know that Edna has very little regard for:
"Supermodels."
"Nothing super about them."
"Spoiled, stupid little stick-figures with
poofy lips who think only about themselves."
Plus, seeing Jack-Jack turn into a "Glitter
Baby" would have been really fun and I wonder
if it's supposed to be an additional power
we didn't see in the movie.
We did see Jack-Jack's mimicry powers when
he transforms his appearance into a reflection
of Edna, but this feels like it might be a
kind of adaptive or camouflaging-type power.
Incredibles 2 is Pixar's longest film to date
and I suspect this scene was cut because the
movie was pretty packed.
Although we do get some fantastic moments
with Edna and Jack-Jack in the final film,
it's always great to see more!
By the way, the clothes in Edna's fashion
line "Mode" were worn by models but still
drew inspiration from the powers of Edna's
favourite clients: Superheroes.
For example, the see-through chiffon around
this model's head was inspired by the look
of a force field.
Next up is a deleted scene that's perhaps
a bit dark where we discover what happened
to Kari the Babysitter after the first movie.
"Hi Nancy!"
"Oh, Helen, Bob!"
"I hope we're not interrupting dinner."
"Actually, we'd like to talk to Kari about.."
"We thought it might be best if we just dropped
by."
"You were supposed to be back late in the
evening.
You left her in charge of your baby overnight
and into the next day."
"Well I'm sorry about that.
That was not planned."
"The er..
The kids kind of surprised me."
"That took us by surprise as well.
A baby's a lot of responsibility for a teenager
and I think Kari got a bit overwhelmed."
"She was hysterical."
"She calmed down."
"She's been twitchy ever since."
"Hello Mr and Mrs Parr."
"Kari, just the girl I wanted to see.
We were talking about when you were babysitting
for us.
Did you notice anything odd about Jack-Jack?"
"Not that I remember.
It's a blank."
"But all those phone messages you left us."
"Phone messages?"
"You don't remember?"
"No, oh op."
"Was that no?"
"What?"
"Jack-Jack?"
"Ha, ha!"
"That's what I'm talking about, twitchy!"
Kari's role in the first Incredibles movie
was expanded when she featured in the short
film Jack-Jack Attack which showed her discovering
baby Parr's superpowers and then having her
memory wiped by Rick Dicker.
This deleted scene from Incredibles 2 is pretty
dark because it looks like Dicker's memory
erasing might have really messed Kari up.
Kari's obviously a fan favourite character
especially since appearing in the Jack-Jack
short so I think many Pixar fans would have
liked a chance to catch up and find out what
happened to her.
However, the answer is a little unsettling
to say the least and given this scene was
one of the filmmakers' options for opening
the movie, I can see why Pixar ended up scrapping
it.
There's an interesting action scene cut out
of the final movie where Edna's high-tech
systems [at her home] begin attacking her
and Mr Incredible.
"I've lost control of my security system!"
The theme that Bird wanted to explore in this
deleted scene was the idea of artificial intelligence
systems turning against their human creators.
If you feel this sounds familiar, you're right
because it's pretty much what happened when
Syndrome's Omnidroid turned against him in
The Incredibles.
Initially, this artificial intelligence theme
was actually the main story for the sequel.
In this cut scene, Bird wanted to show what
could happen if high tech systems like the
ones Edna has became corrupted.
This idea of corrupted A.I.
was eventually abandoned though in favour
of the Screenslaver villain plot, perhaps
because it might have felt too similar to
the Omnidroid twist from the first movie.
This action scene, which has vibes of James
Bond about it, does look pretty cool though,
and Bird has said he might still explore the
A.I.
idea in another movie.
Incredibles 2 opens at a very fast pace, pretty
much picking up with the Parr's facing off
against the Underminer.
However, originally, Bird planned to kick
the movie off at the Parr family home and
remind us of how it was destroyed during the
battle with Syndrome.
"I hate to cut short a tender moment, but
unless you wanna explain this to a crowd?"
"Come on!"
"When they notice I'm gone, just say I went
to call Dicker, OK?"
"Hmm, OK."
"Hmm, Dicker."
"Mr Dicker, it's me, Violet, Violet Parr.
You know how you just drove us to our house
and my parents are superheroes?"
"Sure kid."
"Yes, yes!
The extraction point.
Down!
They'll know where that is."
Although it's a fun clip, it's not as good
as the action-packed opening scene we did
get, especially as it doesn't tie in so well
with the very end of the first movie where
the Underminer suddenly popped up.
And here's the bonus Edna and Jack-Jack scene
from the Auntie Edna short which shows what
happened the night after Bob left Jack-Jack
with Edna while he got some sleep.
"OK, come out and show me."
"Walk it, yes.
There it is.
The room is yours."
"They are lucky to be in your presence."
"Now the turn.
Yes!
You are a tiny god!"
"Dada is here.
Let's show him how fabulous you look."
That turn Edna gets Jack-Jack to do is just
adorable and when she calls him a "tiny god",
it's a call-back to the first movie where
Edna was frustrated with not being able to
legally design for supers anymore.
"Feh!
I used to design for gods."
Also, notice in this scene how Edna has been
making a list of all of Jack-Jack's powers.
The movie revealed at the end that Jack-Jack
has a total of 17 powers and, so far Edna
seems to have 14 of them on her list, but
intriguingly there's two new ones listed under
Edna's "Elemental Shift" category called "Smoke"
and "Liquid".
A promo spot for the Blu-ray release shows
what these look like.
It appears that Jack-Jack can turn into smoke
allowing a ball that Edna tosses at him to
pass right through him.
Then there's a shot of Jack-Jack where it
looks like he can even turn into a literal
water baby.
These two powers didn't show up in Incredibles
2, but if you'd like a full breakdown of all
of Jack-Jack's other 17 powers, tap here to
watch my Jack-Jack Powers Explained video
or click the link in the video description
below.
Now, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been included in the movie?
Let me know what you think of them in the
comments below!
Tap left to check out all my other Incredibles
2 and Pixar videos or tap right for another
video you're sure to like!
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share would be fantastic.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!